you went to Vegas okay yes okay so it
you know let me tell you ever been to
Vegas yeah during March Madness
it's a great place is it not dude so
Paradise in advance of or like before
March Madness you know it's crazy so
when I went for siva's wedding
they
had the table limits up at the hotels
and we asked them why are they so high
like it felt kind of random they said
March Madness coming up but it's like
that's how far in advance of March
Madness that they anticipate people
coming to Vegas yeah that like two weeks
prior already no no not not people
yeah let's be clear dudes yeah it's the
boys it's the boys
not like when you go to Vegas on the on
a normal random weekend what's the ratio
normally when you're walking through a
casino or you're at an event it's
normally 50 50 about
yeah or even maybe sometimes skew more
women because if you're at something the
bouncers are always like you got to
bring girls yeah
yeah this was the this was the most
amount of dudes I've ever seen like guys
just in general in one place it isn't my
life it was the most amount of guys I've
ever seen it's the guys and and every
single one of them was the exact same
person yeah except for me I was the cool
one yeah
we were we were very actually we were
the we were the cool ones we were the
unique ones no I read that I actually
saw an article it was like most unique
guy in Vegas this weekend Cody KO is
here to really shake things up in the
midst of fraternity brothers and sports
fans that was actually the first
paragraph yeah I think it was a it
wasn't like a Vogue article about like
the the fashion of March Madness Vegas
weekend yeah and it was all pictures of
you and it's just yeah exactly it was
like it was like 30 posts of dudes and
flip-flops
and then me
wearing Crocs our guy yeah
yeah yes
30 pictures of dudes in like gym shorts
and like checkered shorts that are too
long with flip-flops yeah
and a college so that was the vibe you
saw did you see any former classes dude
we went uh uh well yeah because we I
mean I went with college friends but no
no but did you run into anyone that was
like oh hey compsi 306 no no vague like
Asians I mean I I honestly probably
everyone there was the
was the exact same we went to this like
it was uh it was called hoops and hops
it was at the cosmo it was like
they took one of the they took one of
the ballrooms on like one of their on
the fourth floor it's like gigantic
Ballroom yeah and they put like 500
tables in there yeah and screens like
along the wall lining the ballroom and
it was there was an open bar the tickets
were like you know hundreds of dollars
it was like way more expensive than it
should have been but you got an open
question are the Hops denoting beer
um so I think that's because you know
basketball players they hop
oh yeah yeah
Hoops is the one is the beer reference
oh okay okay got it got it all right
continue yeah so Ballroom screens
picture this 500 tables boys are locked
up every there's no I didn't see a
single woman I'm not kidding I didn't
see one
one of the bartenders it was a woman
that's it
then they had then they had a they had
like three like you know like little
golf arcade game where you like roll the
ball they had three of those set up
they had a whole basketball court set up
where unprompted dudes just started
playing knockout for hours if you were
going to the bathroom you'd stop and
play like around a knockout with with
other dudes it was just the most amount
of guys I mean I liked it
you know yeah you're just chilling
exactly I went there to gamble with the
boys so that's
that's what it was so who who'd you pay
a visit to did you go see Vanna you see
Larry
uh saw Larry I was trying to find we
said Rich Little Piggies Rich Little
Pigs I was trying to find that one I
couldn't find it but we did play some
other Pig themed ones so we tried to you
know usually we stick to nautical themed
ocean themed but this time because you
were telling me about Rich Little
Piggies I I did try a couple livestock
themed machines oh did you get on corn
did you play corn no it wasn't corn it
was uh
oh it was the it was the one where the
piggies below the or the wolf like blows
the house it's like a Little Red Riding
Hood themed oh I haven't seen that one
okay
I don't know about her no one was
actually hitting
yeah dude so what was your uh what kind
of spins we talking here one cent two
cent five cent no uh no five cent we
were spending uh five bucks
five five dollars a spin yeah
so you know so you could you know that
could be one cent
oh yeah sorry what was the denomination
like what was the yeah yeah okay we were
one time we accidentally had it set on
five cents so you let alone 15 spins
yeah so we were doing 15 spins and we
watched a hundred dollars like evaporate
and we were like wait what the [__] just
happened
if you say weed you guys gamble is a
unit yeah
he'll sit down on the machine and go
okay how much are how much are we in and
then we each have to put in the same
amount and then he spins
and then maybe I'll spin whoever
whoever's like got the hot hand you know
that's genius so Sam puts in nothing and
he gets all of you drunk and he gets you
all to put in something no no no he he
puts in money too it's always but it's
like he'll never put in money and then
just play just him with us watching it's
always like we all got to be in which is
fine I like that yeah that's fine I
think that's good he's taking you down
with whatever the pain is yeah
um I mean we had a couple we had a
couple insane runs I mean I'm talking we
hit a couple um stupendous wins a couple
Mega wins
um
just like every every synonym
for good
you know you'd hit like a big Spin and
it would you get another one of those
spectacular win oh right one of those
before so you're on a run how high would
you say you guys got up
because you're you're rich you couldn't
even see the number of years yeah it
doesn't mean enough means nothing to me
one funny thing that happened at the uh
at the hoops and hops yeah
um was I go out to put a bed in I'm
betting on Yukon right
[Music]
and Devin's from Connecticut I think his
brother went to UConn right it's the
only game that's about to start so I'm
like okay I'm gonna go bet on Yukon
because everyone else did now real quick
is it Yukon or you can
I believe it I believe you like are you
a fan of the team
yeah I love you yeah yeah yeah they're a
good team definitely a good team yeah
yeah
um I should have did that to this guy
actually
I should have did that to this guy I
walked to the front of the betting line
and this dude's like all right man give
me something dude who who are you
betting on I need something I need some
info like give me something and I'm like
uh I'm betting on uh Yukon and he's like
okay okay why why are you Banning on
Yukon this guy you know back backwards
hat like feathered hair
shorts flip-flops
College zip up same guy as every other
dude he's like why Yukon and I'm like
dude I'm I'm the wrong person to ask man
it's because my friends my friends are
betting on it he's like ah
come on that's it that's all you got
yeah I know they've been on it so I'm
gonna Bet On It he's like all right all
right okay that's fine though tell me
about your friend tell me about your
friend what does he know does he know
anything and I'm like I don't he's from
Connecticut man he's like ah like I
stabbed him in the [__] heart
it's like come on betting with your
heart man I imagine that room was like a
a
stack Overflow user base in real time it
was only five percent of the guys knew
all the stats the numbers players who to
pick
whatever and everyone else is just
making posts in there yo wanna bet who's
good
I think a lot more dudes in there knew
the stats because like every table had
like betting sheets and they were all
like out with their pens
like looking at the odds like writing
down their bets before they go to the
the like the booth to put it I guess
yeah you're not you're not gonna pull up
the hoops and hops like looking like a
bozo exactly I was I felt like I kind of
was out of place a little bit because I
was the cool one first of all and the
unique one and the cool one oh yeah I
wasn't like any of the other guys in
there I was the cool one no that's what
they said when you walked in like you
walked in and they're like oh [__]
that's the guy that was in the paper
with the most unique outfits this
weekend
he's not wearing flip-flops what the
[__] that's crazy damn how does your how
are your feet supposed to breathe I
don't know those guys looking at your
toes just wondering yeah
what those piggies look like closed toe
man it's kind of weird yeah bet your
feet stink you're hiding something in
there sweating in there sweaty little
piggies let's see them